[Music]
the Fab Four reunited amidst rumors of
tension et has all the details
this is the first time we've seen them
back together as a foursome since
Christmas
Megan Marco Prince Harry Kate Middleton
and Prince William joined forces at
Buckingham Palace on Tuesday to honor
Prince Charles and all things Wales this
was a a pretty special party it was to
celebrate the 50th anniversary of the
investiture of the Prince of Wales and I
was told by the palace that it started
off as quite a small celebration it's
why you didn't see all senior members of
the royal family there today but
actually it escalated into a into quite
a party it took over three or four rooms
at the palace the event was hosted by
the Queen and everyone including Camilla
were there
the duchess of sussex knows how to dress
her growing bump Megan is looking very
pregnant at the moment of course we
don't know the exact due date she is
believed to be around eight months
pregnant now but doesn't seem to be
showing any signs of slowing down
Megan looked angelic in a white Amanda
Wakeley coat and floral metallic
knee-length dress while Kate with
equally as stunning and a pastel colored
midi dress with ruffled sleeves and
buttoned details and both women were all
smiles throughout the reception despite
rumors of a sisterly feud from what we
saw today they seemed very comfortable
in each other's company everyone was
very relaxed there was no signs of any
tension you know no suggestions of any
rift between the Fab Four and good news
the Fab Four will be back together again
soon we're not going to have to wait too
long for another sighting of them
together in fact on Commonwealth Day
next week we've been told that the
Sussex is and the Cambridge's will join
the Prince of Wales the Duchess of
Cornwall and the Queen of course Megan
and Harry just returned from a three-day
royal tour of Morocco and they haven't
missed a beat since despite Megan being
very pregnant
I think Prince Harry has tried to
encourage her to slow down a little bit
but you know Megan Megan is a grafter
she is a hard worker so I wouldn't be
surprised at all to see the Duchess
working really hard pretty much up to
her due date she'sshe's looking great
she's full of energy and her feeling is
really if she can work as long as she
can this side then she'll take the
maternity leave obviously once the baby
is born now the Duke and Duchess have
sworn they don't know their baby's sex
but we have good reason to believe they
might there were some rumors coming out
of that infamous baby shower in New York
that she was openly telling people that
she is expecting a boy who knows the
truth is we don't really have very long
to wait to find out whether they're
having a boy or a girl
[Music]